all right hey guys welcome back to the
stream we're here with the most relaxing
a nice tub thank you so much for joining
us this is the second-to-last challenge
that we're gonna be doing it it's been a
long day
error okay it's the second the last
thing we're gonna be doing again today
and I just want to thank everybody so
much for being here with us on this
magical adventure that we've been having
so before we started once again we're
raising money for Save the Children
which is a wonderful charity
organization that just it improves the
lives of children all around the world
they make sure that they have their
health care needs their prenatal stuff
their post natal stuff their natal you
know they have everything that they need
to be able to thrive and also helps them
provide them education and make sure
that all the children around the world
have and just last year they helped 187
children and it's a great cause that
we've raised a hundred and thirty seven
thousand dollars for wait its million it
snowed 187 million children yes yes yeah
and that's amazing
so what we're gonna be doing for the
next hour is we're gonna be getting in
this icebox and we're gonna be reading
everybody convinced the donation over
this next period we've got candles it's
very relaxing in here it's a good time
donation all donations are donations
twenty plus because the donations 20
plus there isn't one set up here no all
the donations because we've been
celebrating the people who have donated
a lot so far but that doesn't mean that
everyone is like deserving the same kind
of credit so if you want to make a
donation look in the description there's
a link to the till to five page or
better yet even better way that
everybody can
right now is going to look at that share
button and I know it's a cliche at this
point but hitting that share button and
sharing wherever you can multiple places
if it needs to Twitter Facebook
everywhere share it right now before
making any donation to let people know
that we're still here
we've been here all day we've sacrificed
a lot we've gone through a lot of pain
we've got more pain to go through in
this ice bath which might be relaxing
might be terrible but we're doing it for
a great cause and we're happy to do it
because this cause is so important so
take the time to share right now tell a
friend tell someone you know just share
it to your page if necessary even if you
have one or two followers anything else
and once you do that look in the
description for till to find calm slash
at markiplier and see if you can make a
donation there have been so many amazing
people that have made donations so far
we appreciate every single one of them
but we have so far left to go even
though we've raised an astonishing 137
thousand dollars we still need to raise
sixty two thousand three hundred and six
dollars and two cents thirty-five
dollars and two cents which is a lot of
money especially to do when we only have
legitimately two hours left on stream so
we got to make a count and you guys can
make it come if you've given thank you
if you haven't please consider so mm-hmm
time right once all at once yeah are we
gonna fit all at once I might need to go
a long way to see if anything you know
why don't you take a longer leg we'll
just scooch all together
[Music]
that's a little bit grace oh you're
thinking like one long run along the
other long that'd be a tight squeeze
I think we can do this oh I think we
should do one at a time so we can really
fully immerse ourselves in the
experience what do you think oh they are
cute oh wait this is way too rude this
is weight title this is not okay this is
not it's totally fine it's not it's
totally fun
guys guys guys remember who this is for
is for the children this is for
everybody who doesn't have we're
suffering right now because there are
those who can't get what and you're
suffering through this exam for them oh
that's very well that's very chilly oh
it's very chilled it's just the water
goes him in your ass
so much thank you too apakah lights
hatch Lutece gesture je Jeremy Chaffin
Tori cherish I'll order love david charm
sonny boy ain't co-op and anonymous
every single one of you who's donating
right now is amazing we're so grateful
for everyone to give mark camp with $100
donation thank you so much mark so much
cured is Jenny
Ava Coleman in tiyanak necro bunny
graceful water buffalo with one starfish
Laura Lee no way Alice vu random dog
anonymous he's about Ted
Brendan Oh huge fan named Jessica Gaskin
thank you one and all so much for making
these damage take over for now I need
sure Thank You Katie
Kendall and I hear oh it's done indeed
the Baroness Natalie and maiya mosaic
Isabelle argh
Rihanna zoomy Haley Brinson Amanda
apakah lights
cop I love you Tyler thinking Justin's
to rush to starfish
shake well Desiree Dixon Artemis gained
in Clark Kristin Ackerman Sofia messy
[ __ ] Benedict tackle $50.00 lucky all
K tuck Lauren virtual Samantha and
somebody else 20 starfish Madison kitty
Amy Johnson Alyssa this is it franca tv7
kb7
less than maybe $20 you might be one for
$5 oh boy Texas $10 huffing Emily gray
Little Miss spoon Irish girl Ireland
destiny Eid holiday ellieberg dandy $10
Enzo Brianna resembling Crossgate world
with $50 Wow the serpent game Filipina
orally with $500 thank you sir Casey a
starfish McKenzie five dollars Phoenix
flames three dollars corn dog cartoon
five dollars Cambria $50 Isaac Clark so
I finished medicine age Derek J
hamburger Nestor can really sweet sar
sleep puppy mint mocha something the
Maddy Maddy had her although can't see
well pumpkin OB Alex James
sorry Alexander and Medtronic rosebud
Grimm's lights on g2 Shirky you guys are
amazing everybody that's making donation
tonight now is incredible this ice bath
is nothing
yeah pain is only in the mind my guys
are making such roads into making this
happen I don't know how many people are
watching right now and yes but judging
by Oh Kyle our Sanders a donate mcdu ice
to pick Christine Angela Vasquez
Katherine Cobb Momo Natalie me bono crow
the fray Emily array of rows Pope my
little mumbles he has Manasa
I can't even read these are coming in so
fast they're good free pilots not Lucas
Carlson and criss-cross gal Jolie Donna
Dickens Stardust peeps Andrew and a Kyle
Turner lucidum kuriboh Megan short
cyclone Casey alien Adam Rachel wall bar
currently Kendall May Hayashi Venus Kish
Khaleesi
Michael player of Brooklyn lethal Nestor
hey wassup come on Santa Caitlin hey and
uh post-op Jessi Nicole Chloe a halo 91
I am trash number one Lilith cartel Tori
this is lil - Terry Jill hand Steve
Gilreath slightly used
avocado question mark maybe Mariana
Casey Rachel Sinclair anonymous Alyssa
Martin Adriana are cool be in zanuck
clothings
Sarge for Akana Madison can something
maria leo
Courtney Trimble Kiwi cat Leanne
temporary copy prim mark and Morgan
family watching work Christian Tyler
Madea Aaron princess Sarah one destiny
Krista wiper or Aria song Steven Cronin
a dark Wharf
Lucille Garcia school ooh Jacob a warm
fire sky five main Katrina Carrasco
Thomas Moore a kiss Ventus
thank you guys so much for all the
nations that are like seriously flooding
in Katherine Stan Ryan Lynn Valeri
Poulos Luna Nova I love you Ethan I love
you too time outs Tim Andy little
fireflies Alexander Lee Alexander Lee
Megan Maguire and Marissa crow domine
cause something to cut off Julia gulia
one to one Morita McCoy oh thank you one
and on there's so many donations coming
through and these are all from
individual people that are giving
whatever they can we still see so many
messages from people that are saying I'm
sorry I can't give enough and there's
people that are donating 20 50 dollars
and they're saying I'm sorry it's all we
can give that's okay that means the
world to us like we come together for
these things
Morgan Megan Cooper Laurie D Tyler hates
lasondra Jenny Calibri Kyosho we come
together for these things because they
matter like we've been doing this for a
year straight we've been doing monthly
strings for a year except for that one
where we still did a campaign but we
didn't stream out of like courtesy Laura
L Serena Matthew tanishka Daphne Lucas
bowel my star star star board Lee
doodling Dylan and Shanna Shanna
something Hanabi amelia danger at
Lockhart Twitter at Marvin's
oh he's something has got caught off
Randy Grier Laurel Pechanga Queen and
Aikido Ashley we do these we've been
doing this
for a year straight a campaign every
single month for an entire year we have
raised probably over one and a half
million dollars we've raised it to to
charity this past just this this total
year including November last year yeah
yeah 25 12 months over 2 million over 2
million
yeah because we've on just tilted by not
including some of the big ones like
January and February we raised a million
plus just on top of that and by I'm only
say like we raised that much money
that's you guys
the community raised the community has
gone so far to show that you guys are
literally the best community on the
internet I say that a lot and it may
sound like hyperbole but I stand by
those words like I mean that 100%
because when you see it happening over
and over every month non-stop the giving
the sharing of the loving the spreading
of goodwill like beyond all the silly
stuff we do beyond us sitting in a
bathtub full of ice suffering just for
the sake of being able to sit down and
read chika Kuro e meelo to Khan's fan
ana
Ava Beth Mele Malia Macy big bucks Barry
- amber Lee Emily Bay just for us to be
able to read your names and thank you
guys individually that doesn't mean that
we aren't appreciative of it every
single day of the year you guys are
amazing from the beginning of the year
to the end of the year to next year -
five years ago - any time in between
because you guys constantly never-ending
ly answer the call any time we ask for
help anytime we ask for you guys to
assist us in something or realize how
something as important or try to show
you guys something new that we've done
you guys answered and you're there for
us and you're there for them and you're
there for everybody that needs it most
and that makes me more proud than
I ever could have imagined to be a part
of it over the last year we've averaged
over $100,000 going to charity each
month that's every month we've raised a
hundred thousand plus dollars roughly on
average to each different charity that
we have done and presented and it's
absolutely astonishing congratulations
to Kimberly with a thirteen hundred
dollar donation one thousand three one
you see mark you literally saved my life
so I want to pay it forward there's more
to that message but it got cut off thank
you so much Kimberly we will write your
name down as soon as we're able to get
out of this tough but we got a long way
to go because Alex Roth do to save each
in madison mark Markieff Anna love and
Amy diamond miles Chloe savvy Jennifer
Australia trespasses Riley camp Alissa
you guys every single one of you that
has been donating he's getting us
another $2,000 just came thank you so
much sir York generous thank you so much
guys just take a second every time you
donate just look up in that top corner
and watch how that that package rises up
how big how many times that just fills
in fills and fills each time that fills
we help one infant gets a medical
package and health package that gives
them life-saving vaccinations it gives
them their prenatal name and natal
nutrition when they're they're born and
before they're born to the mothers and
then it also gives them their first
medical visit and that's just the
beginning of what save the children does
and in the entire world over 120
different countries they help in crisis
situations they help in general with
education health and so much more so
much more it's absolutely incredible
what they do and it's it's incredible
what you guys are doing right now and I
mix I'm ecstatic for how much you guys
have been donating we need to keep going
because we can really
maximize this effort when we hit that
$200,000 goal when that donor puts in
that matching amount when we hit that
goal it's gonna be absolutely incredible
to watch and it's gonna be something
supposed to happen we don't know exactly
what but something happens when we hit
200,000 that it's gonna it's just gonna
be incredible I so thank you everybody
so much for donating we're not stopping
here we've only been in this bath for 60
minutes as an ice bath as long as
possible as long as you don't submerge
your chest he won't be subject to
hypothermia or frostbite okay I trust
you TT banks mech eight one five eight
nine Joey
gosh Graciela Fuentes anonymous
anonymous thank you guys so much
Mia Sione thank you guys they're just
like flying through home you put your
feet some crazy jokes uh yeah that makes
it real bad I can't far enough it's
because your extremities they don't get
as much blood flow kiya a chubby frog
Eric Henderson Allison famil ttan john
mccain original syllables Zack one
starfish Thank You ash papi Jenna bomba
Nina
Michelle Aiden Craig Cecil Van Kirk a
Dorcas plier love from italy lina
awesome autumn possibly cut off Megan
Taylor Ava
dig around Lily go green shiny melon
soda Madeleine Madeleine old Kelsey H
Neve Matteo Jess Simpson Kellyanne barn
Amanda asked Austin Johnson Ali Traci
Rodriguez endurance jams of blonde steel
Karissa Alice Mallory Dixon
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious back
of London burg Montgomery Andy pettite
hotel with three hundred and ten dollars
and athlete patel thank you so much I
just want to say thank you for being you
I was at a dark I think I I think I cut
off a little bit there but I was at a
dark time in my life I think it's Mike
what you sing and I'm just happy that
you were able to be part of this
community and find this like where we
are today Tyler take over some reading
here for I'm gonna try I keep trying to
submerge my feet the coolest thing too
is my mom all of the donations are
flooding in and all of the herbs are
more than double today score ticular one
dollar CJ has $20 Fred Gomes one dollar
Rachel's like ten dollars amount of us
$10 J $20
Elizabeth w $20 thank you guys so much
for what you do actually the lawyer $5
mom has $20 rib rob22 $20 Priscilla
$2 this is all I can give that's
incredible apakah lights five dollars
blue well a 151 $1 Toria Nicole five
dollars been two dollars an ominous $15
drink five dollars save the children hi
mark Tyler and Ethan
thank you hello senpai Chan five dollars
mark effin love at mark a fan love a
hundred dollars hey Mark you saved my
life
mr. galaxy star another hundred dollars
from you thank you guys for doing things
like this Nicole five dollars
Cole Hatter five dollars Brianne Brogan
ten dollars boy gave literally something
two dollars and one cent guts five
dollars dark wolf one dollar
Sean
sender strung $20 Lizzy Monday $20 a
blue boy $1 is about $10 smoke that
something $50 Chris $20 vt scribbles $3
retold Swit $1 dark applier $2 box you
Mon $5 Katie Kilmer $20 bebe $5 a $5
charrisse $1 Winston / clover $1 Delaney
Roche rolek $5 macaco of 850 dollars
anonymous $20 Douglas Bailey
$200 Chrissy Eid $20 $5
Ethan Olivia had $5 Delaney Cramer
another dollar and Nicole's mom $30
not just for free $20 ser $5 reviving
gravel 42 dollars and 40 cents almighty
ever raise Zilla $10 my name is tied to
what made $2 [ __ ] chelsea marie $20
marty chrissie $20 the sir soto $50 the
crazy neck $2 Morgan $50 Keira sparks $5
inhale my $5 inhale my dog $10 $25 nice
I did something $20 Jim the tiger $1 not
miss $20 Jade $5 there's so many
donations will it stop non-stop and yeah
we're just gonna sit in this bath and
we're gonna keep reading and I'm just
gonna keep thanking you because this is
the second the last thing that we're
gonna be doing tonight and we started
this segment with one hundred and thirty
six thousand hundred thirty-seven maybe
we're currently almost we're just about
to hit 150 thousand dollars which is
fifty thousand dollars away from our
goal and and that means we got $12,000
in 22 minutes that's not see that's the
power of theirs that's what we can do
and that's what we will do here and
that's what we're gonna keep doing it
until the end of this and if you guys
have given and
like we haven't read your name we're so
sorry about that we want to read
everyone possible if you're giving now
and I can't release it with a $500
donation thank you so much second $500
for me Lisa I don't think we've written
Lisa down you know give me big Lisa give
you big he said John Cobb with $100
you guys are everything about this and I
know I thank you endlessly I know I make
a late night vlogs and I talked about
how grateful I am and how much I
appreciate but I can't help it like I'm
not a I'm not a very nostalgic guy in
terms of like possessions but I am a
very nostalgic guy in terms of
experiences because I very much value
the things that led me to where I am
today I feel like you guys know that I'm
a workaholic you guys know that I do a
lot of stuff but I do it because I love
it
I love it so much like I went on a
hiatus because I thought I was losing
the love of it but it wasn't the love of
the videos it was I was focusing on the
wrong things about the videos you know I
was focusing on what wasn't important
and I was focusing on things that
weren't making me happy when I make it
but things like this where I'm able to
come up with an idea where we can
actually like make the livestreams that
we do dynamic and interest along as
there's so much and not saying that but
as soon as you did before we're boring
but you know you do this for five years
and you know I know I can do better I
know I can always do better every time I
do something and that sounds to say this
stuff that I do is bad but every time I
do something I always know I learned
something from that and I'm gonna take
what I learned and I'm gonna apply to
something else and if I'm not constantly
doing that then I'm not wrong as a
person and I'm not growing as an artist
if you can even call me that and there's
so many things that I want to do in life
and there's so many things that I want
accomplished and yet every time I look
back I realize what I've already
accomplished and the people I've met
along the way and everything you guys
have done to inspire me then just think
I'll always say thank you so anyway back
for more names
Benjamin Moore Yoshi Raul panda snakes
Marvin dunmer van de tiny Monica Daniel
are June $5 Theodore is $1 Austin
Conklin $20 Kelsey C $20 event are $5
Orlando guy $20 Samantha send six
dollars and 66 cents Arnie I can't get
much hope this helps it does because
that's twelve thirteen dollars and
twenty thirty two cents any amount helps
at all because everything you do need is
doubled it is going to be matched by our
anonymous donor up to our goal of
$200,000 it's absolutely incredible to
see all these donations flooding in and
realizing every time we read them that
they're really gonna end up being double
what you guys are doing so every dollar
is two dollars every thousand dollars is
$2,000 yet it's Nablus we have $200 is
$400 give it Ethan a sorry that was a me
is pure Katrina hands and kidney - Ethan
throw something Kristin Ackerman Jeremy
miles boys illicit J's Eric Cody Swain
Gabriella broad Adriana Ryan our mom
Steve Rochelle
Quinn and Kel anonymous Mike mica Riley
Milo's potato space jelly bean soup
Toria the
birdie-bird the apocalypse Luke M be
lethal Nestor Liam Olivia buttery static
miss with $100 ash lamb jnana with 6969
oh there's another $100 oh yeah in me
sneer hi love your work it brings me joy
thank you so much Andrew Caldwell
Kendra Sydney tired Clemont
lonely Wolfie and Bullock cooperation is
PE Ireland Passman Bri Hayley slowly a
starlight 250m there guess Simpson
camera player markiplier game with $2
yes cerulean star like Keira Berryman
poop jokes actually Eisenbach Samantha
Moss Johanna the James Lennox vixen Jess
Hooper Molly
Isabelle Maddie cakes Joel Lily the wolf
Dylan Compton
Shari Kenny babe Emily berry Alex
Macaulay you guys don't stop don't ever
stop and I know people are giving some
sometimes people get all day together
and we would never ask more than you you
could afford to give but if you give
then also share tell people about it I
don't ask that for my benefit it in fact
me this whole event spamming it it's
lost me subscribers just because I
spammed people's feeds when I put all
the events up in line yeah and the a me
with another two hundred dollar
donations tree Sarah April priest
Angelica Vasquez Melanie miles Kimmie
loves cake here take over you take yeah
so it's like I don't say share because
I'm looking for more shares on my
channel coffee with another $100
donation a Neil cherry tart with a four
hundred dollar donation thank you so
much doing these easy books yeah I I
don't do this for my benefit sharing is
really the number one way hundred and
twenty five dollar donation from caseous
thank you so much there's so many like
double digit and double and triple digit
donations is so crazy
yeah and again it's important to note
too that although today the donations
are being doubled with someone matching
it even if it wasn't being a will you
guys making any donations at all is so
so generous and it'll all go this is
such a such an amazing cause so just
thank you guys so much for being here
month after month after month like we
were saying before or how we've
consistently raised
as a community over $100,000 per stream
every month is so amazing so thank you
guys so much
yes chef Justin Becca
Megan seaman maybe kitty amber Kelly
Fred Gomez Ethan will you dot dot dot
Sam question mark miles lease lap Ethan
into we don't know what it is and I
believe there are also still $50 shirts
with at least forty three dollars out of
every shirt going to the charity the
only ones that are left under the
incentives are the extra-large shirts
and the extra small shirts so one XL and
extra small are still available and they
do get shipped to you all across the
world and the shipping is going to be
taken out of the donation and that is it
and like I was saying before like
sharing really is the one way to get
more people into it even if you've been
pestering your your followers your
friends all day long incessant sometimes
is the key to every bit of success never
stopping never letting someone else stop
you when you know what you're doing is
good especially spreading the word about
a charity especially spreading the word
about saving children like when it comes
down to that and even getting one more
dollar into this dream like getting not
to us we didn't we're not making money
we're sitting in an ice bath we don't
touch it we don't touch it it all goes
to good and if you can get just one more
dollar one more dollar month after month
and knowing that that non-stop effort
will work it pays dividends it does the
world of good see Harry dark wharf give
Ethan a Buddha Aden zero K Kate
ding-ding
Haley's and a Rachel PA trust Abigail
Edward Alexander $100 donations each lck
jacob Crippen anonymous amy simpson luca
light 69 Rosie Jackie
Katie obsidian dragon Katie with a two
hundred dollar donation and then I'm
sitting dragon with a $300 to marry
Betty Taylor Kelsey see mirrored IV Dana
Theo
Nils Bjork save net neutrality awesome
panda question mark maybe play huniepop
Ashley Connor
georgeanna Robin rice Ally majestic Liz
hashtag starfish Belkin ace Alan Smith
Cambria our savory Dakota P epochal I
pick all hopper salty spitoon
spittoon group chat oblivion an ex-slave
and exotic Chloe ribbon growlers thank
you
unicorn anima skate is sin making short
three burns below average use so Jeremy
Miller with $1,000 Oh Jeremy Miller
working on your boots my turn
our mark fan love Easter Bunny so much
massive Dawn's sleeve
Angelita yellow man Sarah he's don't be
love okay mark all gay marlisa wallaby
christine nest inkwell oh my god working
on me please stop I can't remember
Jeremy
Ethan Johns redo act Kristen Ackerman
Gabriel Yaya and Ray Becca by our and
keep it up Haley ah rod Maron
[Music]
thank you so much mr. McDonagh
no one imports our eating sparked a
little berry macaque in the shin high
steel Frank Gomez Devante Jones Lily the
wolf school of up and up with a $50
donation Thank You Natalie Hayley price
in Nevada does Jan the tiger
Elizabet wait a second are we 5800 60
holy [ __ ] we've gone so far and that was
just in 10 minutes
ah that's like six thousand dollars in
ten minutes
it's unbelievable what you guys can do
it really is and it's still going up I
think we just got a 400 dollar donation
from kale thank you so much you so much
Zach Alexis Zamora Derek and Holly and
Lilia are - c30 Oliver like Marky red
Jasmine age - the lemon Jasmine H with a
$100 donation god they're junk gem the
punk an eco seriously thank you guys
everybody who's been goating I know this
is silly and I know we've been
constantly talking in circles about the
same thing but this is what we need not
a penis $20 yeah I oh I forgot to finish
my thought yeah I lost subscribers
because I posted a whole bunch of videos
all at once it was a I think
nerd cube did something similar where he
tried to post his series Netflix style
meaning all at once and it was big
blocking people's subscription box that
was just like people just unsubscribe
and but for this like I didn't see any
other way to do it because I wanted to
do something where we could do a whole
big variety show like an alive variety
show cuz I have all this know-how in my
brain about how cameras work and how to
do live streams and [ __ ] and I mean
we all do but I mean this is like I know
I can do all that we have the equipment
like why aren't we doing it why why
aren't we doing it is like we should do
it and we finally did it and this has
been an amazing laughter it's not even
over yet we've still got this and we're
gonna play cards against humanity' with
a bunch of twists like in the next one
but it's just so fun it's so fun and
it's gotten such a good response and I
just love it I love pushing myself to
new like limits and I know it's in an
ice bath and it's stupid but I love
doing that I love just testing myself
seeing what I can do with my knowledge
and that's my favorite thing if I'm not
pushing myself and I'm not living you
know and I always want to always want to
make sure that I stayed true to that era
carry on Christian chat $10 we had a $50
donation from Nicholas Samantha we $20
lures Laura Soros $20 Brianna Becker $2
meme meme Kenna me me Kenna $2 $0.19
Lilly aura $10 Gregory Spring five
dollars and 46 cents that's all I can
give you have one dollar Claudia Larson
five dollars Olivia
$20 you are amazing people know you guys
are the amazing people we're just
sitting in ice you guys are donating and
making such a huge difference
Samuel boy $20 not me at $10 - $10 ma
remark tend $1.00 $200 donation form is
again
then here's another oh my god 20 votes
kinda builders lots of other dollars no
$3 Katie heard $250 one more time
Ali Magette Magette ik $1 s third
Michael $2 sorry I can't give more
that's perfectly fine that's absolutely
incredible
anonymous $20 this anyway
Victoria guzzling $5 Langdon Alexander
Kat $8 money boy
$10 - Mallory $5 David rev up those
fryers $1 $1 Jennifer such great $35
keep it up guys $3 we're almost there
Troy story $19 deska Wilson $30 mission
home Ramos Ramos
$20 good luck guys back at again $1
putting your feet lesbian Sollers hey
good work you guys no good work to you
this is this we are sitting in ice you
guys are doing everything and it's
absolutely incredible literally doing
nothing literally kale $200 they give
Hale just mentioning made my life thank
you so much no thank you you were making
such a big difference in so many
people's lives just with that donation
alone Abbi Maxine $1 won 17 cents Andrew
erect $5 anonymous $10 Chloe baskets $20
Andrea $3 katie the ha one dollar and
fifty cents how he rocks 200
[Applause]
it always hurts me getting $1 faith W
$25 he's x ec bug like know if you burn
a $1 list the lost girl $5 Kris zu v ol
$20 Caleb Mikael $5 Schrag $20 again
I've seen that name come across so many
amiyo yeah Logan dollars and four cents
the lemon got $1 again slow tune $20
give Ethan a hug $4 your local loser
dollars
Hayden Craig $3 fries market food $20 oh
so they're still rolling nonstop it
never slows down and I can't say thank
you enough
we really appreciate we've been in this
bathtub for 38 minutes 30 minutes we got
in a little later than we started and
[Applause]
would make me so emotional to donate
every Gabourey thank you everybody and
we really like I'm really just gonna sit
here for the next 20 minutes and we're
just gonna keep reading
but non-stop I just want to say to the
people that
$62,000 time that's not so amazing we
don't know we do these strings every
month and I want to give a special shout
out to the people that we see over and
over again every month we see some
people that are giving every month it's
like like clockwork they they'll they'll
give $20 one month they'll give $2 and
other months to say like sorry didn't
that much saved up and you know how like
touching that is you know to hear that
someone thinks that donating two dollars
just because you know they didn't have
as much
balance is like a bad thing and it's
just like oh god I can't even imagine
the kind of dedication that takes to
live your life and still set aside so
much not just really in general with
charity efforts but for the stuff that
we do like that's amazing
because I it's it's so special it's so
special what happen like when I when I
first start doing charity livestreams
babies when I first started doing
charity livestreams I I did it after the
very first event I ever won to which was
calm come to San Diego with my brother I
came back from that I had 2,000
subscribers at the time I thought I was
the hottest [ __ ] on the Block you know I
thought why I'm gonna make it this is so
great amazing I wonder if I'm gonna get
like I'm gonna be a big youtuber someday
and then I went in there and I five
people recognized me in that place five
real people five real human beings came
to me one of them Arlene has met me
every year since 2015
yeah and that left the biggest
impression in my heart coming back every
single time I've gone back you know
Arlene I've met every single year there
and it means the world and when I came
back from that convention I it was
concrete trues day like true life I even
made a vlog about it you can still see
it on my channel to this day I came back
and I was like that changed me I know I
needed to do something good with this
community and that was back when I had
2,000 subscribers like our dollars a
hundred dollars from Ella Helms thank
you so much 50 from Bryce Hanley like
Here I am
six years later ray you're so close mil
Jesus here I have another Jasmine age
good God Japanese thank you so much
another blade almost six years later I'm
sitting in a my stove and that first
string we raised $1,000 a hazard 24
hours and I was dying but I remember
being at that strand 24 hours by myself
there was at most like 50 60 people in
there at a time
24 hour streams alone are Starks yeah
autumn summer camp sigue Victorian with
a hundred dollars those hundreds are two
hundred dollars their meaning matched
they're being convinced every single
dollar is being matched here and and
after that like I was instilled and such
such a feeling
kaylynn priest was donated $60 or
earlier everyone keep it up like to come
this far and no that's so much good and
you know I never want to be like
pessimist about anything we do here but
you know after we were doing the last
few streams I was I was thinking like a
hundred thousand dollars we were hitting
that consistently every time and then it
was getting hard sometimes and I was
like all right you know I wonder you
know if that's like the limit and
there's no limit there's not a limit
there's more incentive this time but the
amount of good that we can do is never
gonna stop growing like the community
that we build is still grow you know
what I just realized in the stream one
you might hit over four million dollars
raised after it's matched if we hit
200,000 and that's total charity
contributions from all of your lives
from us ever since your YouTube career
start that's crazy
Yuma Venus with $52 blabber to be from
Athens girlfriend the Iliad and mega
course potato girl kind of break it down
the key it's sloping oMAFRA dog Carolyn
bear without her dolls it's it's insane
the finger but I don't take a single
vinaigrette
I am trash number one 2000 is $130
double
Andy Avenue again $150 this is the last
one I can give tonight you've done so
much holy we're gonna put your name up
of the stash Andy Lizzy you put Andy I
put Avenue you put Patel like it's just
it's never-ending and then I'll put this
you know before I'm into another okay
without hungry again last night I for
some reason I went on my YouTube page
and I saw the first video or first thing
I was ever a part of like on your
channel which was the charity livestream
for Uno's yeah I just saw the thumbnail
and I was just sitting there thinking
that was in December of 2012
really that was five years ago that'll
be five years ago next month
what's the name that I put Patel pa te l
yeah it's it's been a wild ride
a merchant family $100 hi Abby with $50
at warm Ethan
Sara Eaton trill a bit Austin no we're
gonna stay there
we're gonna say anything we got it at
least another ten more minutes that
we're gonna be in there you'll make it
no I'm fine I just can't Breanna's ooby
yeah yeah we wrote them Oliver you look
at look at what we did
[Laughter]
[Applause]
don't embark I don't know why but this
Andy turned out really good you know
before the mystery life story when it
raised $6,000 yeah
going from that and that was like I
still and that's on the unbelievable
amount of money for charity but I would
say I stepped away from that like oh my
god our Google is 5,000 missed six and
we did it in eight hours
oh god yeah and you know
Oh Terry out of dollars before he in the
string and started yeah uh-huh
Jerry did the video didn't go up until
like 11 o'clock at night yeah cuz it was
it was crazy yesterday we were planning
it all day long they're all separately
going down getting stuff
I was running tech from like two at 2:00
p.m. to like 8:00 we filmed that video
right after that I went back i me a name
we made 8 thumbnails together I ended
the video threw it up and then went to
bed at 1 2 got up at 7:30 came here and
it's I love days that just you never
know when it stops because just just
always moving
but once this idea caught and everyone
at the team was just like save $100 yeah
I can't stop donating we're almost there
worse I'm not gonna let up and out
not until we reach our goals thanks Ryan
here alright my body is numb eyes get
out I'm gonna go full length ways cuz I
can't stick any more than my butt yeah
my back
into this because my knees can't wait
we're going full-length wait I'm like
I'm gonna submerge my whole legs when
you get when we get out okay yeah
someone can do that yeah yeah Ottoman
Italia we just you know it's it's
never-ending and as much as I say about
it it's just it's super honest you guys
are awesome get even an electric blanket
this electric blanket would you like an
electric donate him donate to wrap me in
blankets after I'll be cozy cozy big how
many blankets do we have here I know we
got three wrap me up like a little
burrito challenge oh man it's amazing
slave us with 101 penny
fëanor fan erotic with $50 China
Caroline give Ethan us also doing the 30
minute breaks I thought it was gonna
like we all were worried it was not like
totally destroy like everything like the
viewership was just gonna plummet but it
kept up every single stream it kept up I
was so amazed
like I know sopra the first stream at
like 55,000 people there I was I was
grown away that's almost a record number
of any any string we've ever had and the
13 expert brakes are great because we
get to breathe we get a plan move stuff
around get the ice ready get get food go
to the bathroom like whatever we need to
do and it just made it you know it was
lovely
and we may not do 30 min breaks like
that but in the next one we may run it
all the way through and have
pre-recorded stuff to roll in between
but it's just I love it you know it's so
fun I I honestly was worried about the
brakes not just because of viewership
but I was wondering because
of how much we would rush that we would
all we got another $200 donation total
right now I was worried because we had
someone I was honestly I was worried
that I wasn't gonna be able to like use
the bathroom or anything cuz we'd be
cleaning up moving stuff around and
after that first one when I was able we
were able to clean the griddles clean up
that countertop and everything like that
it was absolutely like that is the most
we've worked cohesively as a team to get
stuff together and work in the past two
days there's like amazed me how well
like we can just drive and pick up like
and do all of it together and then
seeing the community right here doing
the exact same thing and doing it way
better than even we in a bit over the
past two days is absolutely amazing it
this itself gives me so much hope in the
world for how much good we can do
throughout our lifetime in here guys
it's like crazy gnu/linux $200 please
say hi to happy in Macy kick up tomato
123 $169,000 let's see how many $69
donations we can get come on can we
knees 69 69 dollar donation give up a
whole bunch of $1600 if we get 690
69 donations we'll probably hit the goal
I didn't do for the next five minutes
we're just gonna straight read names
super Elysian Brice Amelie Luna Park F
knee Tony Allison Trevor Holt's the
traveler one Sammy s with $40 Trevor
olds have $50 hashtag same even with one
dollar slugs Julia darling Sarah and
Daniel Hannah be the lemons gun if you
want to make a donation the link is
right down there and there
anonymous go to tilt to find out complex
at Morgan Clark I tweeted it I fixed
name foes they're everywhere
keys are in a variety a Mariah Elliott
benkler Cindy ho Elliott benkler you
wait Elliott benkler you may have pushed
that button three times you might wonder
choose - giggles Megan ray and bring
Ellie Mike shubao $1 so good draws deep
something it's going so fast
mark I can't read it that's nice about
Matthew Melanie coral demon with $200
$20 I'm gonna sue its Twitter Stephanie
a Adkins 10 Heather with 20 and Clark
amber Jenna may stay gold Ponyboy
she doesn't anonymous le decay Dominic
Emily Weaver Madea multi-cat bear put
blankets in the bathtub episode grandest
end those who 69 cents and then he loves
Ethan with $50 handily Bryson with one
dog Kinzie Lane was $5.00
Wilfred work ties with six dollars and
90 cents Kane Hoffa corekai Nicolas guru
thank you it's sherry chase short Sedona
graceful water buffalo who we see so
often graceful water buffalo you're
amazing
Pat art maniaci miles family loved
Christ and Wars
Ashley Juarez with big food are all
herbs
Hayley Johnson Jack sakti Abba Callie
Fang Shanna
Miranda new Kia Tigers inspiration Riley
a man with a hundred dollars at war Blue
Boy not right now
more or less our Jim Justin with $96
Rachel Valhalla alien Linda miss Lina
Hanahan banana $2.00 shanties and no
after James mashed potato to Gorham
Tyler to the Maddy
Amelia burrito even Alexander League
shares are low this month with $5
Melissa $10 bout it co mix nax $2
sterling d $10 keep striving Mallory
rainbow Fox sorry
Rebecca Smith maja from Canada 5.7
donation today's and mama it's not much
that's of course it's much that's so
much Riley Kendra anonymous with 20 we
may see with 35 Riley Campbell with $20
sorry I can't get more mentor PNG with
another $1 donation blanket one more
donations $14 total you are awesome
David Genie been back up Barry please
play hurry sighs excited 20 people
investors where's the spittoon ass it's
back at my place I'm pretty sure teenie
Anderson Haley a rice gum
gabriella motor thank you $3.00 bluster
not stirred
where's the Squidoo now mitt mitt Joe
Michiko Jenna banana notice me senpai
$1.00 beard black balance 16 I know is
Kristin Ackerman $1.39 on out Lasker
with $30 blankets in dryers crews love
from something maybe the Corgi 6905 see
ya Kayla 69
same babies and know that in Ferguson
Samantha Hudson $10 Claire $20 kini $2
grind and step $50 an DM site 3 dog
Quintin buyers my co-stars and Courtney
doubles Jada
berrak Cora and $60 a mantis gambit 430
[ __ ] every boss Carlo with Vicky
Donor every boss hello Terry Anders Oh
Kayla knows 20 my village
oh damn it Jordan see our East ebook CD
anonymous Hannah banana
but with $2 a fourth time today at Boise
it's funny way it's Jonas six minutes
female math twenty dollars you guys are
making me cold explain Taylor I don't
know Liv dogs $1 emerald deal diable
easy it up Chloe KY Erin London
Sabrina Ashley angel brewery and Dana
Brown thank you that was $5 straight
those five minutes straight of non-stop
donations $173,000 that means we are
twenty six thousand five hundred dollars
roughly away from our goal nope just
[Music]
just put that one on the floor all right
thank you everybody so much
we're not done because watch out cuz I
was going in then get this one camera
get out of here
Tyler oh there he goes
it's good for your knees so thank you
guys so much for being here you're
awesome
we can't tell I am full submerged from
my legs my legs like some full submerged
yeah so we really appreciate this last
drive we raised damn near forty thousand
dollars
oh it is absolutely astonishing what you
guys have done we are not done yet but
we are that much closer to our goal we
don't even have to do what we just did
to get there we are so close and we are
not stopping because after this we're
playing cards against humanity' and we
have got a lot of punishments to go
through so stay tuned we'll be back in
30 minutes with the last segment of this
charity livestream but you guys should
be infinitely proud of yourself for what
you have done we will be reading more
names we'll be encouraging you guys
we'll be celebrating everything that we
do here from all of us to you we'll see
you soon in just 30 minutes
go get a break go get some food and
games donations going yeah keep them
going we'll see you soon bye guys bye
see in 30